welcome to this video that's a good
opponent IAM written master Bablu this
is here krishnan does the krishnons Ozzy
kieran i'm probably mispronouncing that
terribly yeah and i'm keeping up with my
king side fianchetto okay so he just
closes the thing down with d5 yeah he's
a very good gem um usually be quite
clearly above 2600 at times on close to
2700 so very good Grandmaster ok so what
is this so i got this traded the
somewhat problematic bishop why do I put
the night though night Jim going back as
a bit a bit lame i can go queen age for
maybe this is something that irritates
him hmm I don't know could be could be
an entirely wrong idea I Scott not be 50
how stupid is that yeah this is a
another problem but okay I should have
just retreated the night I really should
ok so maybe do this first before he
comes comes with 95 and no f5 is this
possible arm is this wrong hmm I can
also play and I cannot have to have to
do this I think you have to interesting
if I take it he has got g4 yes hmm I
seem he might come up with f4 as well I
cannot take f3 now so maybe I'm going
back for impossible night h6o nice
playing really quickly here so let's
trade Quincy okay he's going up with
this night before now but no
hmm interesting yeah there's some very
very clear question here where where do
I put my king ever I might save some way
I don't know how can I have to take it I
guess yeah castling long doesn't feel
very safe but yeah maybe I have to I
guess after it doesn't doesn't happen
that often that you cast a long in any
King side fianchetto setup but it seems
necessary here see believing that this
is a bullet game maybe just play very
quickly okay oops no I get the blonde at
age seven I really blonde at age seven
don't know what that's so bad for me I
don't believe that
Jim it's just lost I mean even though is
playing almost instantly it cannot do
much it's just too bad this position
Bishop b4 is coming next yeah blundering
h7 was entirely entirely geotech yep
King v8 ok let him play but should be
fun yep black resigns yeah I'm
plundering age 7 I mean I don't know
it's just uh just totally unnecessary to
do that yeah and yeah white is better
but not not as much as after this this
is just just stupid giving up giving up
the pawn here the compounds to go rook
g8 it doesn't want to take now maybe I
sorry to take to play you form e for
this that's definitely G for coming and
that is indeed a problem well the
problem is that a six is a weaker he can
always if he goes night you five it's
very difficult Mikey em so I know I
played this almost automatic move but it
just gives away h7 for nothing so I have
to do something else maybe this is what
the engine is suggesting
hmm no it's not it's not particularly
doesn't it's not much fun to play this
it's always 96 now it's just not a good
position so probably probably this is
true that I have children that I have to
avoid the e4 move I mean I I really
didn't see G for coming that quickly and
it's definitely the right right move
it's definitely the right move I was
thinking apply he plays 94 or something
but that's true that's wrong g4s much
better the engine wants to go hook g8 oh
I for one of those two yeah this is this
really yeah this is really a lot better
in comparison because he really i have
some some kind of counter play on the
gphone imma take here check this is this
is not King not so clear him understand
computer gives gives us about equal
which I don't really get I would still
think white is a bit better here and I
know it goes up now it goes up the
evaluation because f5 is weak I mean how
do I keep the pawn in the long run not
quite clear now it's not a great
position so but i think the now i'm
pressing this bomb near clicking this
button hello no an interesting question
is if Bishop age six is good in the
first place this is maybe yeah not a
good idea to trade this it just takes
too long and he had night be five which
she did not play because he was an
instant move mode he played every move
immediately night b5 was one already
mentioned during the game and it's a
problem I have to play
yet now that is much stronger than what
he played g3 is good of course it's not
not bad just not be five is better okay
I'd here I have to play Bishop g4 I was
I was concerned about 95 and this is why
I went Bishop d7 but this is much better
intending to to use this this weekend
square it's funny the computer gives
this reply which is very unhuman but
funnier because if i take I'm actually
having my my night trapped very very
nice so here night g one which is a move
that i don't really believe that the
human would play in bliss chest but may
be interesting and then preventing light
beyond here I should have thought for a
moment really I was so glad that he had
not played 9 p-5 that I went for that
immediately yeah okay I can go F 6 in
this kind of position but here and then
we we get to this I went here that
that's in fact also an interesting
question if I have to do that I can also
go rook Jade if I think I'm okay here I
think I'm roughly okay don't don't
really see what White's big advantages
maybe it's got a slight advantage in
some way but i don't i don't really see
it
now my making of course a problem I mean
long castles it's not a very ideal
solution that probably is a bit better
but it's um it didn't need to be as bad
as it as it became in the game g4s is
very strong in Nigeria the real real
problem is it it's a tempo on the a porn
so I'm always losing a move and then he
goes and ghost night you find them
that's not good a queen f6 what a silly
silly move but that's already a very
very problematic to defend okay well
thanks for watching